I don't know the difference between a
rifle on a shotgun shotgun is a I know I
feel like they're like too lenient I
know that they are not as strong as I
would like them to be I grew up in
Buffalo in New York State I didn't have
a gun in my house I didn't really know
anyone who had a gun we forget that
there's the rest of the entire state
feel like we're gonna have answers that
what you hope it is my actually is it
might be true you can buy a gun at 18 in
New York true true oh all right
21 knew you wouldn't have a good day
long ago age laws are kind of arbitrary
and I wish there was some sort of like
maturity test as a good trick question
them I'm going to early based on like
video K what does a perm is that just
like being like getting a license yeah
so I'd like a marriage license right I'm
starting to feel like it's maybe a
there's a lot of laws in this thing
right yeah I'll be we'll see
shotgun I think I'm going hand gun hand
going small the rifle and shotgun you
can just walk into a Walmart buy it easy
now that's different than a permit oh
you register your gun when just to let I
would say the government know that you
owned the gun and a permit is like a
license to drive a gun I'm gonna say
that is true if you needed a permit to
purchase a handgun in New York State
then you would be registering your
handgun a state of New York so this is
false you do need to read oh yeah you
got
I was trying I feel like the gun laws
are so crazy that sometimes you never
know
I love the phrase burglars instruments
be unlawful entry into a building I'm
gonna say a none of the above yeah I'm
gonna say D as well amazing good job
just knowing how difficult it is to
acquire gun in New York it actually
makes me feel safer overall they're good
laws but obviously there are some cracks
somewhere because too many people have
guns if someone from another part of the
state came into an area in the state
that had different laws that's really
difficult to arbitrate in court the gun
laws in New York City I mean it's just
such a large population of people in
such a condensed area it's good to know
that there's a heavy restriction good
job New York